one of the dog commandment says thou
shalt not have chocolates why is this so
this is because chocolate is toxic for
them
let's try finding out how and why the
main culprit here is the toxic substance
called theobromine which is present in
chocolates it's not only harmful for
dogs but for us humans as well
however as humans we can metabolize
chocolates easily so unless we don't
consume chocolates in large amounts we
are safe dogs on the other hand do not
have these specific enzymes to break
down the chocolate they process it very
slowly allowing the toxicity to rise
into their system so slower digestion is
what makes chocolate harmful for dogs
but what we also need to realize is that
the toxicity of theobromine is dose
dependent this means that the overall
effect of chocolate intake depends on
the amount and the type of chocolate
consumed more the amount of chocolate
eaten by the dog greater will be the
theobromine consumed by it
for each kilogram of the dog's body
weight if it consumes more than 20
milligrams of theobromine it becomes
toxic and different types of chocolate
have relatively different amounts of
theobromine in them white and milk
chocolates contain the least dark
chocolates on the other hand has about
three times more theobromine compared to
that in the milk chocolate baker's
chocolate has about 6 times more while
cocoa powder has almost 12 times more
theobromine so darker the chocolate more
will be the theobromine it contains and
greater will be the harm it does to dogs
so now we know that since dogs cannot
metabolize chocolate fast it proves to
be harmful for them
but do you think chocolates could also
be harmful for other animals actually
yes
for example chocolates are more lethal
to cats than dogs this is because cats
do have low metabolism rate for
chocolates in fact even lower than that
of dogs but what keeps them safe is the
fact that they are not attracted to
chocolates like dogs are the toxicity of
chocolates for a particular animal is
determined by its rate of metabolism of
chocolates but now consider this curious
question at any point of time in our
lives could chocolates prove to be
harmful for us as well
[Music]
this will only happen if our rate of
metabolism for chocolates decreases at
some point in our lives but is that
possible curious we leave this Q box
open for you to explore let us know
about your findings in the comment
section and don't forget to subscribe to
our You Tube channel do share this video
with all your dog loving friends and let
them know the harm chocolates could
cause